hello guys welcome back to the channel
and if you're new here my name is dami
and i am a licensed architect in
beautiful vancouver bc and today we're
doing something different
for the first time ever on this channel
we're doing a little q a
to mark the 50 000 subscriber milestone
before we start i should say
um thank you
thank you so much for supporting me and
the channel
and thank you for giving me your time
thank you for sharing your thoughts and
your concerns and it's been a really fun
and rewarding process hopefully i can
continue to make videos that you guys
find helpful and interesting let's just
dive right in why did you become a video
creator
and start your youtube channel it was
obviously to
provide tools and strategies for young
architects to have more fulfilling and
meaningful careers in architecture but i
think
this question wants me to go
a little deeper
and i think it's really asking me about
my personal
selfish reasons for starting a youtube
channel i've always been really
interested in like content creation and
sharing of ideas and different
communication methods for architects and
i always thought it was a real shame
that architects just like
share the pretty pictures and we only
share the finished product and we never
really share the process
which is what you're paying for when
you're hiring an architect i think i've
always had a kind of entrepreneurial
mindset
and
i've been interested in like starting my
own business or a side hustle
but i have also worked at small firms i
see a lot of problems with the
conventional architecture business model
i think some people
can
run it very successfully but i'm
personally not interested in starting a
conventional architecture firm having a
youtube channel has been super
interesting for me because
um especially on that front because
uh although i'm not really like properly
monetizing my youtube channel right now
there is the monetary value that i could
tap into if i wanted to and that could
like supplement traditional architecture
firm it's actually like introduced me to
some really cool clients without having
me go and seek them out
and so with this
i think i would be
much more open to the idea of starting
my own firm i think the more interesting
question is how did i start the youtube
channel and it is an interesting story
that i have shared on this channel
before in march of 2020 i ended up
leaving my job when i got my
architecture license i just wanted like
a fresh start
i had been at the firm for like three
and a half years and my bosses were
amazing they really helped me through
the whole process but yeah i just wanted
a different scene and i also wanted a
little break i booked a little trip to
mexico and i've always wanted to go on a
yogurt dream i booked a yoga retreat
super excited but
that's also uncovered hit that was
pretty scary
the markets just plummeted nobody knew
what was gonna happen nobody was hiring
and i thought that i had made the worst
mistake ever because i'm a planner
having that kind of uncertainty
especially right after i kind of reached
my goal that i've been working towards
for
almost a decade
that was very scary and frustrating
it was a very anxious time in my life
during that time i
was i had a lot of free time
and i spent a lot of time
on reddit and on youtube
uh because i was spending a lot of time
on like architecture forums on reddit
one of the things that i noticed is that
there's like a lot of negativity
in architecture a 14 year old kid will
be asking like oh hello
i want to be an architect i
but i don't know anything about it can
you tell me
you will get these like
angry architects being like never go
into architecture
only go into it if you
plan on
working for 80 hour weeks and never
seeing your family and never sleeping
that made me feel very
annoyed because
that is just really one small side of
the story i think a lot of people
say those things thinking that they're
protecting
young people but what they really should
be doing is trying to change the
industry from within instead of like
ruining
young people's dreams that was just
something that i was kind of like in the
back of my mind
at the same time i i was trying to
suppress my anxieties no i was trying to
control my anxieties not suppress
and so i was doing a lot of like
sketching and designing
and then
i came across a video on youtube by ali
abdal where he was like talking about oh
how i made all of this passive income
through youtube
that kind of
lit a light bulb in my head and i was
like well why don't i just try to make
uh record my design process and so that
was my first video where i recorded the
process of me like turning anxiety into
an architectural experience if you're
interested i'll leave it right here
okay next question
just got an internship opportunity but i
feel like i'm not actually qualified
do you deal with imposter syndrome at
all
um
yes
and
until very recently i had imposter
syndrome like all the time
and
didn't know when i would stop feeling
like this like some people just seem to
have this confident as soon as they come
out of school but um i was definitely
not like this yeah like i felt like i
was
this blind person walking around in the
dark for a very long time especially
whenever i would talk to
uh engineers i was very scared of asking
the wrong questions because i was
afraid that they were gonna find out
that i didn't know anything yeah like
trust me when i say this
you will get to a point where you feel
more confident when you do something
once you're kind of like okay that's
what it's like
and uh you don't really feel scared
about it anymore when i went through a
project once that whole process was
terrifying on my second project like i
kind of knew what to expect and it was
actually a lot easier every project you
go through it gets a little bit easier
and you get a little bit more confident
well for me like one of the areas i felt
super impostor syndrome me about
was uh yeah like talking to different
consultants and contractors yeah because
i was afraid that they were gonna find
out that i was a fraud and judge me and
look down on me for not knowing things
actually what i realize is that they
don't expect you to know everything and
usually they're super good about
explaining things to you in fact some of
them love explaining things to you
mechanical engineers love talking about
toilets
of course like to a certain extent
especially if you're a new intern don't
hesitate to ask just remember like if
you don't ask something you don't know
like you're never gonna learn
and this stuff
it's honestly
just so much easier to just ask and like
rip off the band-aid than try to go off
on your own and try to figure it out by
yourself because you're gonna spend so
many more hours like trying to find the
answer by yourself when you can just
look stupid for five minutes and figure
out the answer by asking someone i find
that every time i go through something
really tough
afterwards i come out more confident in
my abilities
a lot of people on this channel ask me
like oh is it really worth it to be an
architect
like it sounds really hard
but for me i think the
internal value that you gain from going
through something really hard is
priceless and the confidence that you
gain in your life
by going through a construction project
is huge you turn this design
and you work with all these people with
all these consultants and clients and
you coordinated with all these engineers
and contractors
and you freaking turn it into a building
that you can go into
if that doesn't give you confidence then
i don't know what will and this gives me
confidence in so many other areas of my
life for example starting this youtube
channel the caveat to this is that there
really isn't a easy fix to the imposter
syndrome in my opinion i think you just
have to go through the process sometimes
you just have to feel stupid for asking
stupid questions okay next question
what do you do in your free time
on vacation as an architect
do you like to separate architecture
from your other hobbies
or do you incorporate it in those
activities as well when i'm on vacation
it
i would say mostly depends on who i'm
going with and what the purpose of the
vacation is and i'm not gonna force my
friends who are not in architecture to
go see buildings with me but
i have found that most people like most
non-architects
love traveling with me because i'm able
to take them to different buildings and
um show them a side of the city that
they wouldn't have seen before and i
mean architecture is a pretty big part
of my
non-working life and it is a hobby for
me so
during my leisure time
or if i'm on vacation i do like to go
and visit buildings also photography and
video making is a hobby of mine so i'm
kind of like hitting two birds with one
stone personally i think if you want to
be a good architect it's important to
visit as many buildings as possible
photos and drawings there's a lot of
things they can't convey as an architect
you need to go and experience what it
feels like
so that it can live in your memory and
like later on um when you're designing
you can kind of pull from those
experiences and bring them into your
designs i dropped out of architecture
and returned to it at 27 years of age is
there a thing as an age criterium when
firms are hiring
i don't think there's such thing as an
improper age in fact i would say it
would give you an advantage um in school
being
a mature student because you have more
life experience and you can bring a
different perspective i think you'll be
viewed as more valuable at work because
firms
generally seem to view
mature people as more valuable in fact i
would go as far as to say if you have
been
cursed with a youthful face like mine
try to add a couple wrinkles in your
face to
look more mature
or maybe a couple of fake gray hairs uh
maybe they'll take you more seriously
i'm just kidding
don't do that how do you handle annoying
or irritating clients if you're just
starting out in the profession
you just complain about them to your
co-workers
when your clients are not around joking
i think it depends on what your level of
experience is and what
level of annoyance this client is
honestly like unless you're a
starchitect or you run your own very
profitable firm and you have so many
people coming to you with work that you
have to turn them down
you don't really have the luxury of
firing a client a client can be annoying
in a lot of different ways and i think
you just have to
weigh the level of annoyingness and that
annoyingness will kind of determine your
reaction
uh but i mean most clients are not
annoying i personally haven't worked
with a client that i found so annoying
that i
never wanted to work with them again
when you say they're annoying do you
mean they're constantly questioning your
design moves because that's a valid
reason and that's a part of your job
so for example um in the library project
that i'm working on right now
every time we make tiny little changes
the librarians they give us uh feedback
sometimes when i'm super
swamped i have like a million things to
do i get like five pages of feedback
feels slightly
slightly annoying but
that is my job actually the more
feedback you get the better your project
is gonna be the client's gonna be
happier that you listen to them well
this is i guess this is pretty needy and
it's kind of revealing of my personality
like if i know that my efforts are
actually being appreciated
then that kind of makes things okay for
me for example the other day we were
having a meeting
with the librarians and we were
revisiting a corner of the library that
we'd
kind of designed
and redesigned
and redesigned the library's
requirements just like kept changing and
different
people working at different parts of the
library had their inputs and i presented
the design once again and they
said something like
also by the way we just want to let you
know that we really appreciate you being
patient with us and uh we know
uh we've gone through this process back
and forth
and them just saying that that made me
feel really good i am a sucker for those
compliments
if you find your client annoying because
the client is slashing your budget and i
think like anything you just
have to put yourself in their shoes if
you had entrusted someone with millions
of dollars like wouldn't you make these
requests if you think it's reasonable
then just like try to take the emotion
out of it try to look at it objectively
my question
is
what are the points we should focus on
while explaining to jury so that they
could understand our perspective
more easier brackets in hierarchy
so i would start with do the like the
why how and what so why present the
problem like site conditions client
requirements and then how how you're
solving the problem
and then the what the what is your
building
and
if you're kind of looking for a
hierarchical list in terms of like the
most convincing
how
i would say
function is probably your secret weapon
as an architect
function is
how you move around where people gather
your circulation path your views all the
pragmatic things about a project that
clients hire you
to solve
and then there's the material
and i think unless there's a very strong
functional reason for why your material
is the main solution to solve your
problem
this should be
yeah second in hierarchy in terms of
most convincing
especially if you're doing a school
project
i always found like
the material as a solution as not very
convincing because you know when you're
in school you're not really working with
manufacturers or actual
like reps of the materials right i think
this should supplement your functional
argument but it should not be
the only reason and then third is form
i've seen architects who design things
by eye
and they make design decisions based on
their aesthetic preference
but
i find this a lot harder to sell to the
client and also
it's a harder solve for your employees
or colleagues who have to work on the
project form should follow function
and not the other way around the fourth
in the hierarchy i would say is probably
like the mood or the feeling
and yeah i would say this is probably
the least convincing argument in terms
of like providing an actual solution to
your
your conditions
um for your jury
but you know also keep in mind this is
how a lot of designers work like they
saw the mood and the feeling
and you know like especially with
interior design like clients eat that up
so
it really depends on like what kind of
audience you're talking to
could you give me some tips on
undergraduate students trying to apply
to schools like ryerson ubc and waterloo
and some tips some portfolio tips
on what the committee really looks for
so if you haven't watched my portfolio
video check that out you are very lucky
my friend
because i actually sat on the portfolio
review committee when i was in my
master's
and i spent many days reviewing uh
undergrad portfolios the portfolios that
have had the best feedback are the ones
that had really good sketches in drawing
when i say good sketches like sketches
where you can see the thought process
and where you can see the person's
interpretation of an object or a
building or a space if i could give you
one tip right now i would say
try to build your sketching skills
looks like i have a fangirl
my question is is it true that you'll
have to sacrifice a lot of things like
quality time with your friends and
family self-care and reading more books
and etc
yes
but also
not necessarily when i was in
architecture school i
definitely made a lot of sacrifices i
didn't
make a lot of time for my
non-architecture friends and family
looking back i was um
let's just say i'm really grateful that
i
have amazing and gracious friends every
single one of them were super
understanding and like nobody really
gave me [ __ ] for it that was just like a
phase of my life that i
had to go through for me you know i made
friends in architecture school and i was
just like really plunged into that world
but i can say that when i started
working i definitely had more time for
other things in my life compared to
being in architecture school and you
know i i always try to make time for
self-care
uh before i go to bed i
have my nightly routine and i try to do
things that i really enjoy doing i make
sure to
finish working
whether it's like my architecture work
or
or youtube or emails
i
try to make sure to finish the night at
7 30
but yeah i do wish i had more time for
reading
for me
making this youtube channel actually was
a huge time sucker and i i realized i
had to
uh reorganize my priorities a lot i was
amazed at how much time
i saved by not watching tv every night
what would you suggest for someone who's
taken a four year long hiatus from
architecture
edit
i mean specifically advice for getting
back into the field what to say during
interviews during the gap
what one can do with their outdated
portfolio
with the portfolio part um i'll just
refer you to my
how to create an architecture portfolio
video try to do competitions or try to
do your own projects to fill that up uh
yeah so actually i've asked a follow-up
question to jessica
who
actually took a break from architecture
due to mental health reasons actually
jessica i don't think you are the only
one i think this question is very
important when i was at my old firm we
had this girl
come in for an interview she had all the
right kinds of skills
but she had a three
year long break when my boss asked her
she kind of said oh i just needed some
time off and that was live
when she left we all thought
she had the right kind of qualifications
that kind of raised a lot of questions
my boss said something like she seemed
like she was burnt out and she didn't
get the job this is kind of tricky
and i think there's a lot of different
ways to approach this and i think it
really depends on how you frame your
break and how you present yourself i'm
not saying this to make you nervous yeah
i think the way you formulate your
answer
can either
really work to your advantage
or it can give off
a bad impression if you
really want to go back to work in
architecture
you have to frame it in a way that gives
you more value
in that sense it's like
how you would reframe
any other work experience you can say
things like
i decided to take some time off because
i was burnt out of my old job and i
think you can be honest about that
and
in fact i think if the employer doesn't
want to hire you because they think
burning out means you can't handle the
workload then i don't think you want to
work there
yeah so maybe you can say
like oh i took some time off because i
was like completely burnt out
but
taking these fears off
and doing other things gave me
time and space to pursue other interests
that shows that you're
multifaceted and you're flexible it gave
me time to reflect on my relationship
with work
and i worked on building healthy habits
so it shows that you're
reflective and resilient gave me time to
reconnect with my passion for
architecture
or find new interesting areas in
architecture
show that you
you're passionate you're freshly
passionate what i found is that
architects really value life experience
like i know an architect who left
architecture
and worked in film for like five years
and he came back and he's now working as
a senior architect even though he only
has a couple of years of experience in
like actual architecture just like try
to spin it in a way that gives you more
experience if you were doing something
for those four years
maybe it's related to architecture and
maybe it's not anyway like i would try
to find a way to connect what you were
doing
during that time to your role you said
you're a fellow canadian
and i don't know like where exactly you
are but uh like at least here in bc the
job market for young architects is like
very very good i'm sure you're going to
be able to find a place that's going to
be able to
give you good
work-life balance the if the first place
that you go to wasn't a great fit
like you can leave it's a hot market for
architects
and
um there's just like
yeah there's tons of places that are
just begging to fill seats yeah good
luck any hints on how to be a good
interior designer so i'm not an interior
designer but i have worked as an
architect at an interior design firm
with other interior designers i think
interior designers have so many skills
that we don't have they're like
amazing in their own right i've actually
been wanting to make a video on this
like the difference between architecture
and
interior design and how that
influences the design process they're
very different from the way they come up
with ideas
to
um like how we present the ideas to be a
good interior designer you need to be
really good at reading the client you
need to be good at turning something
that's very elusive
like feelings and moods
and like branding elements and like
colors
and
turn them into like a material palette
and color palette
and spatial arrangements
because they don't have the hard
constraints like architecture
they don't have things like zoning or
building codes or like site conditions
to play with so they're really just like
selling a mood and a feeling and then
yeah that would be the other
important skill selling yourself and
selling your work because if you're
convincing the client of a mood or a
feeling
you need to be very expressive with your
words
and not be shy with your words i have
actually decided to split this video
into several parts i wanted to dig into
these questions and answers a little bit
deeper
and in fact i did ask you guys whether
you would prefer
a live or if you would prefer me to
like go into these questions deeper and
88 of you guys answered um like a full
deep dive video it's actually pretty
late now so i need to get some sleep i'm
gonna continue this tomorrow i'll see
you in the next video
you